[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by Jacob batalon who
is the star of Reginald the vampire
which it premieres tomorrow at 10 pm
Eastern on sci-fi how you doing today
Jacob hey man I'm good what's going on
not that much man I'm really excited to
talk to you I'm honored for you to even
be on my show and this is just great
work by you and the script also
surprised me how sharp and funny it was
but also your comic delivery in this
show so did you do any improvising here
yeah you know I I think um you know
Harley and Jeremiah and all the
producers were were really trusting of
me to take this character and sort of
make it into my own and there was times
where we had you know discussions on
whether or not we should do certain
things or or convey certain things and I
think that it all turned out really well
um and it was a big gamble for them you
know I don't I wouldn't trust me with
with a bag of chips so it's like with a
whole show man yeah no but they they
definitely made the right call here and
also being the lead of a show like this
is that feel like kind of being the
quarterback of a cast like is there an
extra responsibility for you on set you
know you know I would say that if
anything else it's sort of like extra
pressure you put on yourself you know
and
um I just I think for me I really wanted
to make sure that everyone that was on
was was comfortable and and felt safe
and okay to be vulnerable and perform to
the best of their abilities because
that's sort of like the culture that I
was I was growing growing up in with
with uh films and I just want to
continue that sort of like Vibe you know
I I don't like when people feel stressed
in their job I don't like when they feel
like they have to perform and they don't
feel good in it I really
I really I relish watching actors grow
um you know in this process so I I
definitely
um that's really where I want to go with
that yeah I like that answer and it's
great that you're so thoughtful about
that and you mentioned to your film
career is there any you've worked with
so many acclaimed actors was there
anything you learned from any of them
that kind of you bring to your work now
and forever yeah you know I think when
it comes to work specifically I would
say just the energy and and the The
Vibes that they brought you know I think
that you find the most successful people
you would think that they'd be Jaded by
the world in my life because they're so
famous and successful but it's as if
like there's still like new people to
the industry they're so excited they're
so hyped and but
another thing that I've sort of gathered
is that there's they understand that
there's more to life than filmmaking and
being in movies and being famous that
have things
like fame or fickle and that what really
matters is what your is is your own
happiness and and you know bringing that
sort of energy and that sort of culture
to other people is is probably the most
rewarding experience for me yeah that
that's great and that's just a nice
message you're saying there too and also
just being in TV now compared to film is
there something that stood out to you
that you liked better about TV than film
ah you know it's it's I think it's the
pace you know I think like I I feel like
I thrive more under pressure in that we
have to learn like 12 pages of dialogue
and then shoot out a complete day with
five different scenes and you're like
well [ __ ] let's get to it you know
and but with movies you're sort of like
sitting around all day just waiting for
the shot to be set up and then like you
know you take like
a solid few few takes and then it takes
another 45 minutes to set up the next
scene and then the cameras for that and
it's like man I just want to ask you
know yeah no that that's great too and
I'm excited for you to see you in this
TV realm and leading a show it's awesome
so everybody watch Jacob crush it in
original vampire which is out tomorrow
night 10 p.m Eastern on sci-fi Jacob
thank you so much for joining me today
thank you thanks for having me on